Messier I would say that I am Messier
and I would say that's correct because
by hike a lot of little trinkets like I
love going antique shopping finding tags
this stuff taxidermy how do you dusted I
don't restore Joe do you even really
have a last name anymore do you book him
up to you and just call you grocery
store Joe yes yes okay we are playing
roses and rose a sip or spill that means
I'm gonna ask you guys some questions
and you have a choice here you have
options you can either spill tell me the
answer to the question or sip take a
drink of wine and you know what I know
it's a win-win for everything yeah I'll
probably drinking a lot of wine since I
want to but I'll be open you know cheers
to being friends and to being love us we
definitely are you guys moved in
together we did it together yeah but
West Hollywood yes we've been living
together since literally we set whole
life yes yeah so we'll begin here with
some questions about your shacking up
together who's here you're gonna sit
Percival I spill I would say that I am
Messier and I would say that's correct
because of my collector so I collect a
lot of things not like a hoarder by any
means by hot like a lot of little
trinkets like I love going antique
shopping finding dates and stuff
taxidermy yeah like stuffed animals
stomach real and those are real animals
that are now stuff yes are in the house
those are they are now but they're
they're like very it's like a Natural
History Museum it's really cool
how do you dust a dead animal
uh maybe I don't maybe the part of the
messiness no but I would I'm not like
freaked out by it by the way every time
you guys do answer a question I have
strength is an equal opportunity
drinking game and everyone - nobody's
drink responsibly
yeah um who's always late neither of us
I would say we're both very Punk you
were a time here did yes yeah well your
five minutes or anything fun girl you're
popping the shows and the producers are
like these two won't stop talking yeah
yeah
we're not fashionably late that must be
hard filming you never know what time it
was
that's true yeah you gotta go well they
wake you up really early
you only get probably about two hours of
sleep a night sometimes what your rose
ceremony nights yeah but it's the
easiest life ever you you go on a beach
they take your phone you have no
responsibilities and you hang out all
day yeah tacos you in that the food is
served to you yeah I don't know I don't
know how people lose it so you enjoyed
paradise yeah we came back like oh this
is great you know I I used to work a lot
of hours and then you go like on a beach
and it's just like alright I'm on
vacation I'm chilling high school Spring
Break all over again
yeah who spends the most money Oh Joe
what do you buy in everything cuz you
don't need that are in your palm yes
let's call you out right try em on your
treadmill and do a little fashion show
Joe is I always found Bujji but you are
busy
I like motels hotels how would you say
that you stayed at the peninsula oh my
god it was amazing what an experience
Joe describes in Japan as the height of
luxury Joe you're living the life we all
want away he's got to do it we just got
to do it you guys I feel like I can't go
back to my thirsty lifestyle anymore
because
with him she's grown too are you gonna
go back to working in a grocery store or
oniy a grocery store at any point
well the grocery store business was not
my favorite
it was videos it's very the hours are
very strenuous I mean it's 12 hours a
day every day I don't know if I'll never
be back in that business again but I
don't ever plan on owning a store again
okay all right back to your living
arrangements who's the better cook my
guy who didn't know how to cook pasta a
year ago isn't how to tell you neither
of you were looking at the other Ken
Bowie you didn't know how to cook pasta
you're like get out of bed put pasta the
first time I cook that I put it in a
frying pan yeah and it still actually
was was you are you all right oh the
only okay so Joe can cook pasta sauce
better than me but every other food
group how good I am
how good is my pasta so this pasta sauce
is pretty bad you can can it put
grocery-store Joe on it and it's selling
out who goes to bed first who's the
early bird we go to bed at the same time
with very punctual if it told you this
who likes to get Randy more often this
is an old school is that sexual yeah who
wants to have more sex in the
relationship guys you can drink or not
the answer I don't know I think it goes
back and forth okay I like to get down
during the day like I said get down yeah
it sounds cool why are they talking like
Austin Powers do I make you run
be like morning I'm night yeah yeah I'm
not morning more afternoon
[Music]
whoo
it always has to have the last word in
an argument yeah I would say both of us
both of us you know my last question for
this interview might be are you the same
person from sexy to gross are you guys
at the phase where you fart in front of
each other these are great questions but
very entertainer actually they're fun
I've never farted in my life Joe
actually recently if I didn't I don't
fart I fart on the toilet
I don't fart I know you have really good
acoustics in our apartment what I'm
saying is I don't feel like I don't I'm
not like a guy that sits on a couch in
my life heard someone justified as I
fart on the toilet that's just going
number two man whoa but me I fart prior
to the number two happening like you
know you're sitting in your home at all
like you did a really tight a sip of
wine at that moment I'm sorry I'm sorry
to people you know everybody goes to the
bathroom we all do we all go number two
so what I your biggest pet peeve about
the other person you can't sit where you
can still I had a really good one okay
Joe looks in the mirror while he's
talking to me okay maybe a fair we have
a huge mirror in the back of our dining
room I love how you don't even say what
Betty no it's just drinks you can't say
one bad thing about each other just
drink you like each other too much it's
fine we're any more wine yes these we
might now you guys are pretty good you
answered a lot of the question we're
pretty
but we might be getting into some stuff
that like I don't even know if you
talked to each other about so let's see
sip or spill really got called it here
for a reason I would say I was like
there's something to afraid this sip or
spill wedding detail
oh okay can was going for it you see
that have you talked about what kind of
wedding you want
yes actually have don't tell okay we
have okay I want some because we have a
really exciting little surprise if we
planned for our wedding but I think well
we I mean we're not even engaged yet and
of course like here's the thing we've
talked about it I don't think either of
us are scared of it no and I think it
could happen I could see it happening in
somewhat the near future
I don't know but any jewelry company
wants to reach out call me at three one
two it's funny because it's funny
because we talked about like different
ways we would raise kids you know well
yeah we're very when it comes to that
we're very different yeah I would be
more of a disciplinary I guess you could
say like I do believe I do believe I do
I do believe it a little bit of that
hard love like more of that tough love
kind of like not everything you do is
perfect because not everything it is
perfect which is good just go over
here's no mistake in say that's wrong
you made me you could do better what I'm
saying is you need all you need the
challenge the kid a little bit I mean
you can't just always don't spoil I
don't believe in spoiling your kids
right sure you can
okay and raising them sad let's bless
trophies
okay would you guys get married on TV in
Paradise I mean I wouldn't want to okay
well I think we've always talked about
getting married abroad I don't think we
have yeah I I know you have I personally
would not want to get married on college
and it just it wouldn't feel I wouldn't
feel comfortable I mean certain people
do it I think it's great I would think
who do you know or who have you met who
you would definitely not give it invite
- okay thank you
so we're transitioning now into our
bachelor nation question oh if you could
put anyone in bachelor nation in the hot
seat and ask them any question you want
who would you want to grow Joe who you
have questions for I don't care so long
Becca cuz I think she's awesome okay
well good thing she sent this guy first
night unbelievable
[Music]
filming your seasons did you ever break
a rule
like do something you were supposed to
do sneak out in the nights go I don't
know sneak a call on a cell phone
to me it was just it was such an I was
like really happy to be on it so for me
I was like I'm just gonna follow the
rules it's so simple it's just like
everyone even a master nation name the
biggest diva you're looking at if the
two of you had to be had to be I'm gonna
throw a threat with someone else from
bachelor nation it's a trouble every
nursing couple Oh a couple yeah like a
relationship who's the person you're
gonna you know what this is another
person in our relationship maybe little
Becca yeah I like this yeah and then you
automatically baby someone we could
discipline so I was in love with Ruth
cute come on all right
yeah you know what you've got one last
sip there Joe cheers thank you guys for
playing stepper spell to ever finish it
up oh my gosh don't eat these they're
poisonous it's Christmas I love you all
so much happy happy holidays whatever
you celebrate thank you so much for
watching roses and Rosie and of course
we'd give you a little holiday gift
enjoy your New Year's we will have more
episodes every Tuesday love you so much
baby
[Music]